[Music]
do you have a large fleet of stateful
virtual machines
how many of each operating system are
there
which ones are fully patched and
up-to-date the latest security patches
and can you be sure that all of them
have the right software installed and
running
for a lot of teams it's critical that
they're able to answer all these
questions but that's not always easy
especially if your infrastructure
includes hundreds of virtual machines
running various operating systems
today i'm going to show you how vm
manager can add clarity to those
questions and lift some of those
operational burdens that come with
managing a large number of virtual
machines in the cloud
vm manager is a suite of tools that help
you manage the operating systems of your
fleet of virtual machines these
capabilities are nothing new there are
plenty of third-party tools and services
out there that help you do some of these
things across your fleet
the advantage of vm manager is that it's
cloud native and works out of the box
with the latest google cloud images
across windows and linux operating
systems
its functionality is accessible via the
google cloud console that you're already
familiar with or via the gcloud command
line interface and api vm manager works
by periodically communicating with the
google os config agent that runs on each
of your virtual machines
the data it receives helps it serve
three core functionalities observability
with os inventory management security
with os patch management and compliance
with os configuration management so
let's talk about the first vm manager
feature os inventory management os
inventory management lets you collect
and review operating system information
from your fleet of vms
this information includes operating
system version packages installed on
each vm package updates available and
vulnerability reports the os config
agent that periodically reports in the
latest data interfaces of standard
package managers like apps yum and
google to collect info on packages and
updates so os inventory management i can
list all the vms in my project
and if i want i can filter that list by
operating system by operating system
version by installed packages by missing
packages or even by pending updates
next we have os patch management while
os inventory management will tell you
what's installed where and which updates
are pending os patch management is going
to let you install packages and updates
through patch deployment jobs the os
patch management dashboard will help you
visualize your fleet and identify how
many are ready for updates broken down
nicely by operating system
the dashboard helps you clearly identify
the machines in your fleet that have
important security updates so you'll
never miss a beat when keeping the
machines secure when you're ready to
deploy a patch you can create a patch
deployment job to run immediately or in
the future once or on a recurring basis
if a patch deployment fails for whatever
reason since vm manager is cloud native
you'll be able to troubleshoot it right
from the cloud console through cloud
logging the third big piece of vm
manager is os configuration management
with os configuration management you can
automate the deployment configuration
and maintenance of your virtual machines
from a centralized place
you do this by creating os policies that
contain declarative configuration for
each vm like packages that should be
present package repositories that should
be added files that should exist and
scripts that you'd like to run
a single os policy can be written to
write a multi-step workflow for example
setting up a repository installing a
package and then changing config files
you can specify how to apply these
policies across your fleet by using
filters based on labels os families or
even regions and zones
once policies are written and applied vm
manager will constantly check to make
sure the policy is enforced
it can also generate a compliance report
that will tell you if any machines have
fallen out of compliance with the
requirements that you specified if you
want to use vm manager of your fleet
here's how first there are two apis that
you'll want to enable on your project
os config and container analysis
then you need to enable os config on
each vm in your fleet by setting the
metadata tag enable os config to true
this will make the os config agent
active on the corresponding instances
you also have the option of adding this
metadata tag to your project so that all
vms are included
each vm will also have to have an
attached service account it'll be used
to sign requests to the os config api
and finally each vm in your fleet is
going to have to have the os config
agent installed
the good news is that this is already
included on the latest os images
available if it isn't installed on your
machines check out the documentation in
the description below for steps on how
to get installed on each operating
system let's check out vm manager with a
quick walkthrough of os patch management
what i have is a google cloud project
with 17 virtual machines running various
operating systems
for this demonstration i have the
patchjob executor i am role assigned
that will give me permission to create
and execute patch jobs in the project
first let's take a look at the os patch
dashboard
from here we can see our vms broken down
by operating system we also see a chart
for each operating system showing us the
virtual machines by available updates
if we click view details on any of those
charts we'll get a list view of our
virtual machines
up here we'll be able to filter the list
by a few different fields
for example by adding a filter on os
distribution
we can view all centos and red hat
machines in a single list with their
zone os info and status if you want to
get more information about a single
machine's available updates we can
simply click the name and get some more
details
under basic info we once again see the
os information in a summary of its
available updates
as you can see down here there are quite
a few updates with different
classifications let's add a filter to
see only updates classified as critical
that narrows things down to three
critical updates
if you want more information about
individual update check out the cve
column you'll be able to go straight to
the cve website to learn more about the
vulnerability each update will resolve
since these are critical updates let's
install these updates by creating a
patch job we can do that right here by
selecting the updates
and clicking apply update creating a new
patch deployment happens with five steps
first let's select our vms
our one centos machine is automatically
selected but we can add more by
adjusting the filter
and selecting all sent to us machines
next is the patch configuration first
we'll give it a name since we initiated
this straight from the vm details panel
the packages we want to update are
already here under included packages
we can move on to step three scheduling
here we simply indicate whether we want
to roll this deployment out now or
sometime in the future we also can
create this rollout on a recurring
schedule for packages that we know we
want to update regularly and the
duration field will let us specify how
long before the deployment is considered
a failure step 4 brings us a few more
rollout options that let us control how
quickly we want to roll it out
the threshold and the percentage will
help to slow down the rollout so that we
don't have to patch all machines at once
and finally step 5 is advanced options
where we can provide vm manager with any
pre or post patch scripts that we'd like
to execute before or after the patch
completes additionally here there are
some post patch reboot options
once we finish the configuration we can
click deploy to kick off this patch
deployment job once it starts we can
click the job name on the patch jobs
page to get details about its execution
the update info page will recap what
this job will be doing and on the bottom
we can see the status of each vm
included in this patch deployment
once finished each vm will have the
status of success or failure along the
link to view logs associated with that
patch job
that was just a simple example of os
patch management in action and only a
small peek at what vm manager as a whole
can do
os inventory management is going to give
you insight into the operating systems
running on your virtual machines and
your google cloud projects
os patch management will make sure the
right packages are kept up to date and
free of vulnerabilities
and os configuration management will
automate the deployment configuration
and maintenance of your virtual machines
all of this straight from the cloud
console
for more information on vm manager check
out the link to the documentation in the
description below
thanks for watching
you